hi my name is markiplier and I'm here
with Mama plier we just got done with
the How well do you know your child
thing now I've got another quiz of how
well do I know you you ready yeah
first question what color are your eyes
and I'm not gonna look you write down
the answers on let me see okay sorry no
known as black eyes as brown next what
is your favorite thing to do okay your
favorite thing don't show me oh I can't
see oh part of me your favorite thing to
do is bargain shopping that is right but
that is right I wish I had to choose
that answer well what do you put what
would you consider to be the nicest
thing I could do for you what would be
the nicest thing that I can do for you
okay okay well I'm gonna go with pay off
your bills but that's a nice thing to do
but not the nicest well why not pretty
nice nice nice but it's not
okay my answer is a little different
here okay what is your answer my answers
as a mom mm-hmm so nice so nice you
never changed you always say then ever
since we were born
have you lost some weight what about
this but it says that other than that
you know changed you saying
your face is hardly changed except you
got a little bigger personality
stiffening happy
looked out in life who's about to say
something better work
nice can't do that that's too nice we
didn't get into the nice questions if
you had all the time and money in the
world what would you spend your time
doing all the time and money in the
world okay yeah all the time in the
world you would travel the world you
would build a compound and start a cult
you'd love to be a cult leader you
wanted it you made a great call leader
what was your answer not a cult leader
see so knows all the time Lord you'd
still be my what does being my mom and
tell would you okay well you know that
your mommy is up it's showing you
stomachs full mm-hmm clean place to come
home to what I was gonna do you can
start a cult okay um what's your
greatest unfulfilled dream you're never
a sinner Oh three amazing you dream so
bad then not didn't come true right
mm-hmm
my answer yeah you know what you know
what truly what was my dream yeah
whatever
ever since I was 10 years old looking
through the thick Sears catalogue Jeremy
have you seen a CEO scared of sighs a
phonebook yellow
my father wrote one
work for us hobby okay just yes cirrus
catalog in the front there's um you know
mechanical stuff black and white and the
bag was color ladies well-dressed
clothing bedding jewelry that was my
dream i before i every night before I go
to bed I'll open and dream to myself and
pray to God someday I'm gonna sleep on
the deathbed nice hi Micah stop that
nice you know nice place I know who saw
me I've come to America to leave
plus bonus this interesting what was
your first full-time job I don't think
you know this one I probably don't it
wouldn't have been it's not nursing or
it's not that it would have been before
that did you do it clean no I hate thing
we talked about she working like a
grocery stores never work there was it
back in Korea when you were working this
well no I think a profession you can
call profession that don't require
speaking in English only skilled you
know together skill you don't have to
say anything other than hello sit down
open your mouth why you're a waitress
the only waitress experience I have
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so who is your closest friend oh oh
yeah what's wrong I don't know we spun
right away she's very persistent
never give up time to go to walk
Lucy's taking Maggie's place is your
favorite what is your favorite kind of
music I think it's like the oldies like
Bee Gees and yeah yeah soft rock is that
what the soft rock is I think oh count
it I count that as Mia getting the right
answer all right how about this one for
a final question how did you meet my dad
honey I couldn't write a book about this
story hmm but I think I'm gonna wait
wait for the book the time to pass maybe
maybe not well you know what if you wish
long and hard dream always come true so
you have to watch what you're wishing
for because it happened to me
remember since I was about eight I wish
to come to America every night I dream
of it
Korea at the top I now Korea our living
situation it's a lot better improved a
lot they make more money and they have
all the convenience right we enjoying in
America 1980s Nestle it was enough for
everybody so when I sleep on the floor
don't don't get it think I'm on the
floor you know what I mean blanket I
wish that I live in America so I can
have a different kind of lifestyle well
your father he walked into my life on
suddenly in spring of 1979 1980 I was in
high school I was invite one of the
soldier who came aside to come to Korea
petina suffer you know because my dad
enjoy you know training new officer
coming to us and Korea and that faithful
there was one that was my moment that
I've measured that hmm sitting next to
my dad
freaking coffee and talking and I was
shy you know what I mean poor young girl
but I had I just felt like I want to be
friend with you with him I want I said
may I may I done how to speak English
from you and he said oh sure I used to
be an English teacher
be glad to so he's been coming to see my
dad and me because he has time he was
assigned to come to Korea for a year you
know that's how we become a friend then
pull a tur he came back and he fell in
love with
I mean I guess you know I lost all the
baby fair I was nineteen twenty twenty
nineteen my hair was a little longer
when he met me first I was like this my
hair was short I had a high school
haircut so it's time to look at me as a
woman not as a girl yeah when did you
come to America I'm on year yep oh also
when I took 20 min one December 21st of
December 1985 that was one of my dream
came true
then Thomas was more than two years
later need two years later after that
right yeah I was not planned right do
you have any uh any other embarrassing
stories that you want to tell about me
is good oh my goodness
embarrassing story that's so many I
don't know where to start here no
nothing embarrassing but I'll tell you
one thing one thing I could tell you
when you are a successful you and your
brother and I and my sister who can't
just hit me from career we went to Kings
Island nice in Cincinnati Ohio some
people and that was very crowded evening
we went there's so many people at
probably Saturday night and I don't know
what happened there was so many people
and I look and I turn and you're gone
you only five barely five maybe four and
I was very what are you calling
Oh Michael I could not believe the the
feeling and then that's I spotted a tall
uniform looks like a police officer
whatever looking like a an office you
know somebody who worked there so I used
to rush back to again my staff
[Music]
it's gone and you know he said he kind
of would smile at me knowing smile I
think I know where is that oh you do go
check on the lost and found place so me
and my sis and you brought a ride she
walked in the rotting over there Ninh
there you are
the most amount of playing with toy all
by yourself
it was nobody lost by him yeah I
remember that the question remember what
I asked what your question was I don't
know you remember no I don't you don't
remember all right no because you're so
little
but I remember because I was mom and I
know how did you get here
everybody said one minute you mom you
were here but you're God so next best
thing I do is I look there was a guy
with a uniform look-alike police officer
so you went there said hey yes sir I
know it's my mom can you help me and he
direct you to the most of all the way
forward I remember looking at the the
big wheel it was a big spin and I read
just I was member of mesmerized by some
law I wanted to watch it all the way to
go back down until it's done then done I
turned around and you were gone and then
I just remember like I don't remember
anything in between like realizing that
you were gone to being in that place
like I don't remember asking a guard
where like to go all I remember is like
I couldn't find you and then I remember
being in the in the lost in town place
like my memories real spotty isn't good
but because I was so desperate you know
what I mean then I asked because I asked
the question how'd you get here
and he said oh that's what happened Mike
and then the guy with knowing smile I
just knew this - he could have been just
like hey you lost your child really dumb
why you any more stories Oh Oh another
thing this is - oui oui I wanta my
invited girlfriend and the girlfriend
had a girl about your age
oh you're five and you and your brother
and you was playing downstairs the
basement something with toy and we all
still talking cooking whatever and
that's minute I heard you crying
you'll cry what happened mom I rushed I
did dead girl's face why I don't know
she just slapped me say what did you
slap a bear you know what you and your
brother never had fun no always played
nicely we fought like on occasion but it
was very rare I never sinned yeah it
wasn't when you were around no I cannot
even remember bad now we were good kids
we're a bit boring in that regard we
didn't cause trouble no we just went on
the woods played I remember how pissed I
was when I realized I had to go to
school
just like the the realization that like
my life wasn't all play I had to like go
to school you wish you play believing
what yeah you only wish to you wish
you'd come to my way my life is not
place oh no not when you do this job
sorry no that's okay that's alright I
wish anyway well this has been me how
well do I know my mom I think I only got
one question right which is pretty
decent in my book so thank you so much
for playing this with me and then thanks
for embarrassing me in front of Internet
and thank you everybody so much for
watching I will be coming to Australia
and Amsterdam Amsterdam in July and
Australia in November you can check out
tickets at toured on marklar calm and
hopefully I'll see you there
mmmm and as always we'll see you
[Music]